[Musique]
valérie tender a l'habitude de monter
sur sa paire formée pour séduire son
public
mais si aujourd'hui le spectacle est
devant des amateurs de country à
montréal il a déjà été devant une
clientèle bien différente
la première fois qu'un homme offert de
l'argent pour le sexe était à baie
comeau
j'avais 16 ans après ce que j'ai trouvé
où sont les clubs bagarre fois ce que
l'autre fait plus que juste danser et
puis c'est quoi un club a girl hot une
expression d'un str hilali kluba gaff
gaff c'est l'idée que une fois que tu
rentres en cabine il ya des services
sexuels
c'est pas juste dans ses tableaux jobs
des complets
le soir c'était son père qui l'a mené au
bar de danseuses un père qui trouvait
bien normal que sa fille se déshabille
devant deux hommes pour valérie c'était
tout ce qu'elle connaissait et l'argent
rend très vite car je revenais à la
maison j'avais un rituel de douche
complètement débile pour enlever la
saleté psychologique où je commençais
par en haut puis je me suis rabattu
visualiser la saleté psychologique colle
avec l'eau du drain j'ai trouvé tout
début parce que les coûts - ouais pour
moi par définition d'acheter une femme
c'est l'odeur et c'est aussi interdit au
canada depuis 2014 la loi criminalise
les clients qui achètent les services
sexuels
en plus des proxénètes les femmes qui se
prostituent ne peuvent pas être arrêtés
sauf si elles sont près d'une école ou
d'un parc où il ya des enfants
s'appellent à l'heure d'acheter le
consentement sexuel d'une personne donc
je vois pas pourquoi on parle de
consentement tout le temps mais que tout
à coup des comptes ajoute l'argent à
c'est correct mais si certaines comme
valérie considère qu'il faut tuer la
demande à la source
l'idée de pourchasser les clients est
loin de plaire à toutes les
travailleuses du sexe
[Musique]
bouger j'ai tout connu le salon de
massage agences de sport un déplacement
puis à la samoa
j'ai fait aussi à mais j'ai fait les
rues g technique le bagage donc c'est
ici que ça se passe
oui c'est en plein ça arrive de la jalle
quand j'ai commencé à préparer du cycle
oui jennifer droit un travail depuis une
vingtaine d'années dans l'industrie du
sexe surtout à québec depuis la nouvelle
loi elle a beaucoup moins de temps pour
évaluer ses clients les hommes ont peur
d'être arrêté il faut tout de suite
monté dans la voiture même si c'est
risqué pour convaincre votre somme
d'argent qui était cette activité leur
vélo tu t'entends pas avec hello
s'affairant du symbole
tu t'attends pas à l'imepo payer il veut
pas me donner le prix que tu veux
ce fait point ce testing avec pilote je
positive
ce n'est pas une nerfs pour jennifer
l'importance et crée un climat
sécuritaire pour les prostituées d'après
elle on pourra jamais protéger
complètement les femmes tant qu'elles
devront voir leur client dans la
clandestinité à l'eau
protéger et aider les femmes qui se
prostituent c'est ce que fait sandra
wesley elle même une travailleuse du
sexe ce soir et prépare la distribution
de condoms
selon m peu importe la loi les femmes
vont continuer à vendre des services
sexuels
un ex des deux sortes de tremblant pour
sandra l'idée qu'on puisse éliminer la
prostitution en criminalisant les
clients et idéaliste et surtout
paternaliste envers les femmes qu'on
croit vraiment que on doit avoir cette
liberté là de disposer dans notre corps
comme on veut et que c'est pas d'autres
personnes décider pour nous si on est
opprimé ou non il est là le coeur du
débat
est ce que le travail du sexe est un
libre choix ou de l'exploitation
c'est pas vrai que c'est un choix actif
là à moi quand j'avais 5 ans je rêvais
d'être prostituées je me disais à côté
sur un mur avec mes bottes de [ __ ] qui
monte jusqu'à occuper archers mais
softimage les deux camps donc très
divisés mais selon cette professeure en
sciences juridiques toutes les femmes
s'entendent sur au moins une chose les
prostituées ne devrait pas et
criminaliser et on doit aider celles qui
désirent passer à autre chose
tout le monde s'entend pour dire que les
personnes qui n'ont pas le sentiment
qu'elles sont dans cette industrie là
par choix devrait avoir d'autres portes
de sortie
et c'est là où le bât blesse car même
quand on veut arrêter de gagner sa vie
avec le sexe souvent la société n'est
pas prête à nous accepter trois ans
travail du sexe dans un cv le set sur
mon cv c'est et je pense qu'il ya une
certaine hypocrisie sociale à l'égard de
soi parce que tout le monde se dit très
tolérant l'égard de la prostitution
mais de même atteint personne
d'embaucher quelqu'un qui sait déjà
prostituées la plus grande barrière à
arrêter travaillent dans l'industrie du
sexe c'est la stigmatisation qui vient
avec
il a fallu plusieurs années à valérie
pour sortir de l'industrie une bataille
où elle se sentait souvent seuls et sans
ressources
je salue au bureau dette sociale c'était
tellement humiliant et faut faire
pression sur nos gouvernements de
libérer des fonds vers l'accompagnement
la sortie bon je cale plus de choix sur
la table pour les femmes
[Musique]
dans ce débat sur la décriminalisation
tout n'est donc pas noir ou blanc
oui la décision d'ottawa de pourchasser
ou non les clients fron nécessairement
des mécontente
mais quoi qu'il en soit les
travailleuses du sexe espère mettre fin
au mépris qui les entoure et plus
concrètement qu on leur donne les moyens
de changer de vie si comme valérie elles
en ont assez
[Musique]
où